good evening for the first time in
nearly a year ccsd
elementary school students were back in
the classroom today thanks for joining
us here at five i'm denise feldas and
i'm brian loftis it is definitely a big
day for those students and their
families as they begin this transition
we have team coverage for you on how the
first day back went over all eight news
now reporter christine drummond leading
our coverage
outside of rex bell elementary school
kristin
brian two special guests coming to this
campus today
ccsd superintendent dr jesus draw and
state superintendent joan ebert both
welcoming back
some of the many thousands of students
around the valley returning to buildings
today
and ccsd gave us a breakdown of the
numbers
now you may recall families did have a
choice of cohort a
b or c now cohort a the first returning
on campuses today had roughly
22 thousand students they'll attend
class monday and tuesday and online
remotely wednesday through friday
roughly 20 thousand are in cohort b
going to class remotely monday through
wednesday
and then in person thursday and friday
and more than
50 000 are in cohort c which is
full-time distance education
since last thursday hundreds of families
have switched to cohorts a
and b from c and dr dara expects that
trend to continue this school year
we've seen that once the protocols are
in place once we start getting going and
are seeing our families feel that level
of comfort that's
what i've talked to of my colleagues in
other districts that have been open
they've seen an increase
in enrollment
superintendent jarrah says a total of
and 4 485 pre-kindergarten to third
grade teachers worked today
nearly three thousand were on a campus
and around fifteen hundred worked
remotely
as for substitutes four hundred and
ninety were in buildings
251 are filling in for teachers and 239
are long-term subs in vacancies the
choice of
hybrid or distance education is still
available for all families to choose
dr jarrar recommends families reaching
out to your child's school
first to see availability for in-person
learning reporting live in las vegas
kristin drummond 8 news now